El agua es el líquido de la vida.
La bebemos,
nos bañamos en ella,
cultivamos,
cocinamos,
y limpiamos con ella.
Es la molécula más abundante
de nuestro cuerpo.
De hecho, todas las formas
de vida que conocemos
morirían sin ella.
Pero lo más importante
es que sin agua
no tendríamos
té helado.
Mmm... té helado.
¿Por qué flotan
estos cubitos de hielo?
Si fueran cubitos
de argón sólido
en un vaso de argón líquido
se hundirían.
Y ocurre lo mismo a
muchas otras sustancias.
Pero el agua sólida,
es decir, hielo,
es, de alguna manera,
menos densa que el agua líquida.
¿Cómo es posible?
Ya sabes que cada molécula de agua
está compuesta por
dos átomos de hidrógeno
unidos a un átomo de oxígeno.
Veamos unas cuantas moléculas
en una gota de agua
y digamos que con una temperatura
de 25 grados Celsius.
Las moléculas se estan doblando
estirando,
girando,
y moviendo por el espacio.
Ahora, bajemos la temperatura
lo cual disminuirá la cantidad
de energía cinética
que tienen cada una
de esas moléculas
por lo que se doblarán, se estirarán,
girarán y se moverán menos.
Lo que significa
que en promedio,
ocuparán menos espacio.
Ahora, pensarás que
cuando el agua líquida
empieza a congelarse
las moléculas simplemente se juntarían
cada vez más cerca
Pero eso no es lo que pasa.
El agua tiene un tipo especial
de interacción entre sus moléculas
que muchas otras
sustancias no tienen.
y se llama enlace de hidrógeno.
Ahora, recuerda que
en un enlace covalente
se comparten dos electrones,
normalmente de manera desigual,
entre los átomos.
En un enlace de hidrógeno
un átomo de hidrógeno se comparte,
también de forma desigual,
entre átomos.
Un enlace de hidrógeno luce así.
Dos lucen así.
Estos son tres
y cuatro
y cinco,
seis,
siete,
ocho,
nueve,
diez,
once,
doce,
Podría seguir.
En una única gota de agua,
los enlaces de hidrógeno
forman extensas cadenas
entre cientos, miles, millones,
billones, trillones de moléculas.
Y estos enlaces están rompiéndose
y reformándose constantemente.
Ahora, volvamos a
cuando el agua se enfría.
Sobre 4 grados Celsius
la energía cinética de
las moléculas de agua
mantienen interacciones
breves entre sí.
Los enlaces de hidrógeno
se juntan y se rompen
como las relaciones en
la escuela secundaria,
es decir, rápidamente.
Pero por debajo
de los 4 grados
la energía cinética de
las moléculas de agua
empieza decaer por
debajo de la energía
de los enlaces de hidrógeno.
Entonces, los enlaces de hidrógeno
se forman con mucha más frecuencia
de la que se rompen.
y unas bellas estructuras
empiezan a emergir
del caos.
Así es como
el agua sólida, el hielo,
luce a nivel molecular.
Noten que la ordenada
estructura hexagonal
es menos densa que
la estructura desordenada
del agua líquida.
Y ya sabes que si
un objeto es menos denso
que el líquido en
que se encuentra
el objeto flotará.
Por eso, el hielo flota en el agua.
¿Y eso qué?
Bien, consideremos un mundo
donde el hielo no flote
La parte más fría del océano
sería el suelo negro
intenso del océano
una vez que esté congelado,
siempre estará congelado.
Olvídese de los panecillos de langosta
ya que los crustáceos
perderían su hábitat.
o del sushi, ya que los bosques
de algas no crecerían.
¿Qué harían los niños
canadienses en el invierno
sin estanques helados para
jugar hockey o para pescar?
Y olvídate del Óscar
que ganó James Cameron
porque el Titanic
no habría pasado.
Despídete de los casquetes
polares blancos
reflejando la luz solar
que de no ser así
cocinarían el planeta.
De hecho, olvida los océanos
tal y como los conocemos
que cubren el 70% de
la superficie de la Tierra
y que regulan la atmósfera
de todo el planeta.
Pero lo peor de todo
es que no habría té helado.
Mmm... té helado.